and welcome to this video and playing
alpha Ilan so again that's crazy there
are number of people in the pool I still
get him all the time what is that okay
taking time out there yeah sloth defense
yeah this line with queen bee three
years frequently seen in my games it's
some convenient way to avoid completely
mainstream lines some me not that this
is very offbeat looking but it is um not
exactly the total main line and it still
poses black some problems from time to
time okay what is he going form c5 I go
rook t1 okay playing a preparation ok
I'm going fruity one anywhere here in
case of e 5 or c5 the rook will be right
now
we did not want to play Knight c3 as
then he goes 94 and gets in some trades
which is probably welcome with him okay
here i can do 93 now I'm quite sure what
else to play actually especially in case
of e 5 I want the knight on c3 oh yeah
interesting moment now how do I play
that now I can go if for which is
interesting if what takes Knight takes
my queen might be a little bit I'm not
sure about it okay let's play that and
see what happens it's not think too long
here okay that says that's this choice
that's a bit awkward this pin is a bit
awkward I'm i wonder if i should just
play age 3 him but he will if he takes
rook takes that looks wrong really looks
wrong
hmm t5 maybe I'm kind of unsure not very
familiar with this kind of position
as you don't see them play for e 5 so
often in this in this type of structure
it's perfectly logical of course just
nothing that I am very familiar with
yeah well she takes I will just take 95
95 okay it's not going for that and what
am I going to do here okay maybe prepare
to play g-form get rid of this this this
awkward pin
yeah this is one of the rap players who
take that time is normally behind on the
clock when we play okay 95
yeah black is totally fine here of
course didn't get anything remotely
anything out of the opening the only
thing I have is a little bit more time
okay yeah here i was thinking night eh
form maybe get the bishop pair or not
maybe i will get it definitely um the
ship g5 maybe I don't know it looks a
little bit should be a bit cautious my
pieces are a little bit of yeah I like
f2 or so there might be tactics
happening
now Bishop will be nice on deform
it's not not a very very comfortable
position really isn't
getting out of this diagonal my idea is
to play look T to now am rooty to look T
to rook to e1 maybe ultimately Bishop e3
yeah okay
now he's very fine here but I'm not sure
if I'm much worse there should be seven
or not never known to a three horses
kind of Miss placing it terribly i don't
know i don't like we should be three so
much so i'm going for that i hope i can
always go to 83 it's a bishop might be
how wow interesting that's interesting
maneuver ing for the g4 man oh man oh
man mera yeah i'm running into simple
it's tough here just g4 of course and
now awkward again what can you do check
and he can get a move da that's the
worst worst part if I would control the
D file it would still be kind of
interesting at least who continue now
look the 30 so ash is killing
and I'm continuing a little bit him
check mostly due to funds frustration
that was really not not necessary at all
he was comfortable with nowhere Nia that
here time morning now I'm just
blundering jacket oh wow what a disaster
it was it wasn't totally lost anyway
heard with them I mean he I shouldn't
use simply there's nothing special going
on here this is okay and now I will it's
maybe not okay I don't know g5 is a bit
awkward already I cannot take it and he
threatening g-form I wanted to prevent
95 of course I'm Kim as usual the
computer is totally cool and just place
that and says it's equal yeah which is
probably true at least I don't think I'm
any any worth substantially here at
least I should should think for a moment
and see that g4s cat is coming i mean i
can try stuff like that for example
which is worse for me but is that this
kind of kind of unclear which this isn't
check HERE black is just winning and he
can get in Luke the aid which is really
awkward that the rooks get get traded on
I have to give up and let him invade
check yeah okay Rudy to was silly but
it's it's this is a loss anyway Jeremy
no I didn't get get anything out of this
and out of this opening five yeah maybe
I should just take it this Bishop h5
move was a bit awkward after you form
maybe I should just just go for for this
kind of this kind of thing
this is simple and and easy to play
maybe I should go for that Bishop h5 was
surprisingly awkward to meet okay well
thanks for watching